my name is Phillip Evans I'm the head of
the grievance office at the council and
my main responsibility is to prepare in
this case the treaty which will be
signed on the second of March today we
are preparing the practical preparing
the text now the German we're about two
thirds of the way through the printing
we're into the Italian language now so
25 pages each language version so it's
sub proximately 550 pages about 4
centimeters of text terrific fit perfect
ready to ready to bind yeah I'm thinking
that we should put the signature pages
in the middle between the Latvian and
Lithuanian let's Center okay we want the
presentation to look good and if
signature pages at the end when you open
the book it doesn't fall correctly this
is a signature ceremony and you want it
to be as easy as possible and it's
erroneous women as possible so that's
that's the simple reason why we're doing
this so the next step is the rehearsals
we shall run through the whole the whole
ceremony with colleagues from protocol
from media for audio-visual team and
make sure that everything is is in order
so that on the day there's no slip-ups
and just go around smoothie first one is
always the most difficult during the
ceremony the book will be taken around
the ceremony room I will be doing that
myself and each of the plenipotentiaries
will be asked to sign
in the allotted space so if you see here
we have Belgium Bulgaria Denmark Germany
dystonia that finished ready to go